Seguro que la mayoría de vosotros habéis
escuchado hablar del proceso de impeachment
contra Donald Trump.
Sin embargo, ¿Cuántos de nosotros sabemos
realmente qué es, en qué consiste y cuál
es la historia de los procesos de impeachment
en Estados Unidos?
Porque amigos, ya os adelanto, que este proceso
es mucho, muchísimo más complejo que un
mero debate sobre la destitución del Presidente.
(La Constitución americana define el impeachment
como una herramienta de máxima excepcionalidad.
Con ella el poder legislativo puede revertir
en la práctica la voluntad del pueblo. Una
voluntad que se expresa con la elección del
presidente.
Por este motivo, el impeachment supone en
circunstancias muy serias la negación del
régimen electoral democrático.
Hablamos de un proceso pensado para casos
en los que el presidente haya cometido delitos
graves, delitos que deben ser claramente demostrados
tras una minuciosa investigación previa en
la Cámara de Representantes.
Estos delitos son, fundamentalmente, casos
de traición, soborno, y otros crímenes o
delitos graves que no están especificados)
Pero … amigos, incluso con esta explicación
todavía me faltan cosas, muchas cosas para
entender del todo cómo funciona el impeachment,
¿no os parece?
Por eso en este vídeo no solo os vamos a
hablar a fondo de este curioso proceso, sino
que también vamos a echar un vistazo a la
historia y vamos a contaros cuántos impeachment
ha habido en Estados Unidos, por qué sucedieron
y cómo terminaron.
Y sí, también cómo no, vamos a ponernos
al día sobre el impeachment contra
el Presidente de los Estados
Unidos, Donald Trump.
Atentos.
(EL IMPEACHMENT, UN CONTRAPESO CLAVE)
Si algo bueno tiene la democracia estadounidense
es que se diseñó pensando estrictamente
en limitar el poder de los políticos.
Veréis, lo curioso en el caso de Estados
Unidos es que tanto la Constitución como
la Carta de Derechos estadounidense son limitantes.
Es decir, si la leéis no os costará daros
cuenta de que, en realidad, lo que dice sirve
basicamente para evitar que el Estado - o
las personas que controlan el estado - ejerzan
excesivo poder sobre el resto de los ciudadanos.
Esto es algo que supone una diferencia muy
importante respecto a la mayoría de constiruciones
del mundo que se centran en definir los derechos
y obligaciones de los ciudadanos.
Y esto es algo clave, fundamental, esencial para comprender
el significado de un impeachment
en los Estados Unidos.
(Los Padres Fundadores establecieron desde
un principio la posibilidad de destituir al
presidente y otros altos cargos. Definieron
el proceso como un juicio político y no penal.
De este modo, el Presidente puede ser apartado
de sus funciones por ciertos delitos graves
sin que ningún juez le juzgue en ningún
momento del proceso.
De hecho, el único juez presente durante
todo el proceso de impeachment es el presidente
de la Corte Suprema, que se encarga de ordenar
el funcionamiento del juicio político una
vez este pasa al Senado.
Pero la “sentencia” - la destitución
- es decidida única y exclusivamente con
la votación de los senadores.)
Sin embargo llegados a este punto puede que
muchos estéis pensando…
Pero, vamos a ver, si esto es un proceso político,
entonces se podrá utilizar para ir en contra
de cualquier presidente que no guste a la
oposición, ¿verdad?
Pues lo cierto es que no. Eso no es posible
bajo el sistema norteamericano.
Para evitar que algo así ocurriera, se
establecieron una serie de complicados pasos
que garantizan que solo un proceso de impeachment
muy justificado llegue, no solo a completarse,
sino incluso a iniciarse.
Tanto es así que hasta la fecha, en los casi
250 años de historia de Estados Unidos, todavía
no ha se ha producido ni un solo impeachment
efectivo.
Es más, en todo este tiempo tan solo se han
iniciado dos, bueno, tres si tenemos en cuenta
el actual contra Donald Trump. 3 en toda la
historia.
Ahora bien, ¿cómo es entonces este proceso
exactamente? ¿Cuáles son los pasos a tomar
hasta la destitución?
Fijaos.
(Lo primero que tiene que haber son indicios,
prácticamente pruebas de que el presidente
podría haber incurrido en algún supuesto
de los que recoge la Constitución.
Con esto, cualquier miembro de la Cámara
de Representantes tiene que proponer el impeachment
o juicio político bajo juramento. En el caso
del de Trump ha sido la propia Presidenta
de la Cámara de Representantes, Nancy Pelosi.
Después, se designa a los comités que investiguen
el caso y determinen los hechos que son imputables
para el impeachment.
Finalmente estos comites redactan uno o varios
artículos que son votados indivualmente o
en conjunto por la Cámara de Representantes,
lo que equivale a presentar cargos contra
el Presidente.
Es decir, para que todos lo entendamos, la
función en este caso de la Camara de Representantes
es presentar cargos. Si lo hace entonces comienza
propiamente el impechmente o juicio político
y todo el proceso se transfiere al Senado,
que es quien juega el rol principal en toda
esta historia.)
De hecho, como veis, es en realidad allí,
en el Senado, donde se produce el juicio político.
Es el Senado la cámara que este caso actúa
como si fuera un juzgado.
Pero en lugar de jueces, fiscales y jurado,
lo que nos encontramos en esta situación
es con miembros de la Cámara de Representantes
que actúan como fiscales, y Senadores que
actúan como jurado.
De esta forma, si los senadores votan por
una mayoría de dos tercios a favor de la
destitución equivale a que en un juicio normal
el jurado declare culpable al acusado.
Y esto en un impeachment no significa otra
cosa que la destitución automática del presidente
y el traspaso de sus poderes al Vicepresidente.
Parece complejo, ¿verdad?
En realidad lo es, pero es lógico.
Pensad que tiene que ser un proceso muy garantista
para que no se pueda destituir a un presidente
así a la ligera, como quien se compra un bolso en el Black Friday.
Pero, ahora bien, después de saber cómo
funciona, la otra gran pregunta que podemos
hacernos es: ¿qué podemos aprender de la
historia de los juicios políticos en Estados
Unidos?
Tal y cómo os hemos contado, quitando el
de Trump, solo encontramos dos casos más
en toda la historia: el de Andrew Johnson
y el de Bill Clinton.
Y… bueno, el de Richard Nixon, que en realidad
terminó en una dimisión prematura y, frente
a lo que se suele pensar, no llegó siquiera
a ponerse en marcha.
Pero ¿Queréis saber más sobre lo que ocurrió
en esos casos?
¡Os lo contamos!
(DOS IMPEACHMENT, UNA DIMISIÓN Y CERO DESTITUCIONES)
La historia de los juicios políticos en Estados
Unidos es breve, muy breve. Tan solo dos presidentes
han sido sometidos a él y ninguno de los
dos fue destituido.
Quizás el caso que menos os suene es el de
Andrew Johnson.
Y no es de extrañar, porque estamos hablando
de un señor que presidió el país en entre
los años 1865 y 1869.
Pero… ¿qué hizo este hombre para acabar
siendo juzgado por el Senado norteamericano?
Pues… veréis, tras el asesinato del presidente
Lincoln en 1865, este hombre, que era su vicepresidente,
se convirtió en presidente.
Y… digamos que, cuando tomó el mando, sus
políticas se alejaron mucho.. de las de Lincoln.
[Vamos, que empezó a volar por libre… Y
de que forma.]
Para que os hagáis una idea, Johnson era
a la vez miembro del Partido Demócrata y,
literalmente, un supremacista blanco convencido.
Un tipo de lo más racista.
Vamos que al lado de él,
Trump sería algo así como un férreo defensor
del multiculturalismo y la diversidad.
(Andrew Johnson defendía fírmemente la esclavitud
de los afroamericanos y se dedicó a vetar
todos y cada uno de los proyectos de ley que
el Congreso aprobaba para reconocer derechos
a los esclavos liberados.
También empezó a indultar a generales de
los Estados Confederados de América, que
para los que no lo sepáis, se rebelaron contra
los Estados Unidos iniciando la Guerra de
Secesión.
Esos Estados, los estados que se rebelaron,
consideraban que Lincoln era una amenaza a
la supremacía blanca, y que tenía un plan
para abolir la esclavitud en todo el país.
Y esto no sentaba nada bien por allí.
Y ojo porque algunos de estos Estados tenían
un 49% de población esclava. Casi nada.)
Pero si esto ya os parece grave, esperad a
ver la gota que colmó el vaso.
Johnson tuvo la genial idea de empezar a cesar
y nombrar a Secretarios de su gobierno saltándose
la validación del Congreso, lo que, como
podéis imaginar, no es legal.
Pero fijaos lo complicado que resulta destituir
a un presidente, que a pesar de estas graves
acusaciones, Johnson se salvó por solo un
voto en el Senado.
Un solo voto hizo que no se alcanzaran los
dos tercios. Se salvó por los pelos pero
se salvo.
Y de hecho, esta fue con diferencia la vez
que más cerca se ha estado de destituir a
un presidente.
El siguiente “intento” llegó con Richard
Nixon más de un siglo después, tras el famoso
escándalo del Watergate en 1972.
(Resumidamente, el Caso Watergate fue un escándalo
que envolvió al presidente y a varios agentes
de la CIA en el espionaje al Partido Demócrata.
Allanaron su sede y pincharon llamadas para
obtener grandes ventajas de cara a la reelección
de Nixon como presidente.
Después, durante la investigación, se descubrió
que las escuchas ilegales habían sido controladas
directamente desde la Casa Blanca, lo que
en julio de 1974 desencadenó  el inicio
de un impeachment contra el presidente.)
De hecho, queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
la cosa fue tan grave que Nixon se quedó
literalmente solo.
Y cómo además no le interesaba que la investigación
fuera más alla [ no sea que aparecieran asuntos
más turbios porque Nixon fue un presidente
muy turbio - tras siete meses de deliberaciones
dimitió justo un día antes de que la Cámara
de Representantes votara iniciar el proceso.
De modo que, en realidad ,el mecanismo del
impeachment nunca se puso en marcha.
El que sí se puso en marcha fue el proceso
contra Clinton.
Ay Clinton, Clinton… ¡Cómo la lió Bill
Clinton!
Podemos decir que metió la pata [y lo que
no es la pata] hasta el fondo.
Y es que seguro que a muchos de vosotros os
suena el nombre de Monica Lewinsky.
(Incluso puede que a alguno os suene más
el de Bill Clinton mismamente, porque a finales
de los 90 estuvo en boca de todos el affair,
el desliz, los… encuentros extramatrimoniales
entre la entonces becaria Monica Lewinsky
y Bill Clinton sin que su mujer, Hillary,
se enterase.)
Pero no os equivoqueis. El motivo del proceso
de impeachment contra Bill Clinton no fue
que el presidente le hubiera sido infiel a
su mujer. Para nada.
El motivo real, o al menos con el que se justificó
el proceso, fueron las mentiras de Clinton
y sus presiones para que otros alrededor suyo
también mintieran con el fin de ocultar una
sórdida historia que mezclaba engaños y diversión
en pleno Despacho Oval.
Y creedme cuando os digo que en Estados Unidos
- al menos hasta la llegada de Trump - eso
de que un presidente fuera pillado mintiendo
- y obligando a otros a mentir - era algo
que no se veía nada, pero que nada bien.
Pero… vale, ya os hemos contado cuáles
han sido los impeachment y cómo funcionan
pero… ¿y Trump? ¿Qué pasa con Trump?
Pues bien… ahora le toca a él.
Y lo cierto es que las cosas no pintan - o
no deberían pintar - muy bien, porque todo
apunta a que lo que ha hecho es muy grave.
Ahora bien, ¿en qué consisten exactamente
las acusaciones contra Trump? ¿Puede este
proceso afectarle de cara a 2020?
Atentos.
(TRUMP, BIDEN Y UCRANIA. ¿UNA JUGOSA TRAMA?)
Amigos, el caso de Trump… viene de lejos.
Concretamente desde nada más y nada menos
que Ucrania.
Pero, ¿qué narices tiene que ver Trump con
Ucrania y qué pinta Joe Biden en el título
de este bloque?
(Y es que,veréis todo apunta a que Trump
pidió directamente por teléfono al nuevo
presidente ucraniano, Volodímir Zelenski,
que investigase a los Biden por sus relaciones
con la empresa de gas Burisma, de cuya junta
formó parte Hunter Biden, el hijo de Joe
Biden, exvicepresidente de Barack Obama y
uno de los futuribles candidatos demócratas
a la Casa Blanca.
Poco antes de esta llamada, Trump congeló
casi 400 millones de dólares en ayuda militar
a Ucrania aparentemente como método de presión.
Y podría ser considerado un soborno a cambio
de un favor. Un quid pro quo.)
Pero esto no se queda aquí.
Incluso el propio Embajador de Estados Unidos
ante la UE, Gordon Sondland reconoció haber
recibido presiones de Trump para forzar al
gobierno ucraniano a que investigase una supuesta
teoría por la que Ucrania habría interferido
en las elecciones presidenciales americanas
de 2016.
Y no, esta vez no en favor de Trump, como
se dice que hizo Rusia, sino a favor de Hillary.
Y ya os podeis imaginar como son las investigaciones
en Ucrania.
En otras palabras, Trump está utilizando
los medios y los recursos del gobierno de
los Estados Unidos para presionar a gobiernos
de países con un estado de derecho más que
cuestionable para que hagan por él el trabajo
sucio contra sus contrincantes.
¡De locos!
Ante estos graves hechos, el Congreso decidió
abrir un proceso de impeachment para investigar
minuciosamente todo este asunto, y saber si
el presidente Trump sobornó a los ucranianos
para lograr su material de campaña.
Y ahí no termina todo.
(Según parece, Trump podría haber creado
una especie de “diplomacia paralela” con
Ucrania fuera de las vías institucionales
a través de su abogado personal Rudy Giuliani,
obligando incluso a Gordon Sondland a subordinarse
a él.)
Ahora bien, ¿es esto suficiente para tumbar
al presidente?
No lo sabemos, pero lo que sí sabemos es
que no paran de salir más y más informaciones
que complican la situación de Trump. Informaciones
como esta.
(Nuevos documentos revelan detalles del papel
de Pompeo en el asunto de Ucrania  New
Los correos electrónicos y documentos publicados
por el Departamento de Estado respaldan el
testimonio que muestra que el Secretario de
Estado Mike Pompeo permitió la campaña de
presión ucraniana en el centro del proceso
de juicio político.)
Lo cierto es que al menos de momento el Partido
Republicano no parece favorable a dar la espalda
al presidente bajo las acusaciones actuales.
Y mucho menos cuando queda tan poco para las
elecciones… [¡Político!]
Aunque esto es algo que podría cambiar si
se dispara lo que en Estados Unidos conocen
como “pistola humeante”, una información
100% contrastada, probada y explosiva como
para derrumbar al presidente.
Pero hasta que eso pase, y si pasa, lo normal
es que con el respaldo republicano Trump mantenga
la presidencia. Recordad que en el Senado,
que es dónde se decide la destitución, los
republicanos tienen la mayoría.
La única esperanza para los Demócratas sería
encontrar pruebas flagrantes de que Trump
realmente sobornó a las autoridades ucranianas
para que hicieran todo esto.
Sin duda, todo un culebrón. Estaremos atentos
de cómo se desarrolle todo este embrollo.
Pero ahora es vuestro turno.
Tras saber cómo funciona un impeachment,
cuántos ha habido y por qué se dieron, ¿creéis
que Trump tiene posibilidades de ser destituido?
¿O terminará en un nuevo impeachment fallido?
¿Qué os parece el proceso de juicio político
como contrapeso al poder de los presidentes?
Dejadnos vuestros comentarios aquí abajo,
y si os ha gustado este vídeo no olvidéis
darle like, y suscribiros al canal, si es
que no lo estáis ya.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.